everyone good morning good afternoon
good night depending upon when you're
watching this video it's morning for me
currently I just woke up I'm not a
morning person as much as I try I set my
alarm every day for six o'clock and I
said you're getting up you're going to
yoga class and I end up just hitting
snooze or until the dog wakes me out so
today we're going to a park and we're
going to start training him on leash
training you guys assured me that it
does get easier and he's about eight and
a half months now
so it has significantly gotten easier
because those first couple of months I
was in struggle setting it you would put
in the GPS struggle city would take you
right to us
I Maddy let's go get your training let's
see what songs on right now cuz you make
me feel
[Music]
it's too early for dancing we can put
this GoPro on
three in a row of Maddie working with a
trainer he's done some training before
but we're back here at the parking very
well it's very proud clearly does not
like GoPro structures
[Music]
all right got some things we need to
discuss today we are going to be baking
something this video is not going to be
out for a while but it has to be baked
today I'm prepping some videos through
the next month or so and look at Matthew
you're making the cake uh-oh
big this is going to be a huge cake ah
Matt how are you at math oh forget about
okay cool because I've got some
questions for you sixteen cakes it takes
about 40 minutes for four cakes to bake
well you can't cheat use a calculator
you can so 40 minutes times four which
is divided by 60 is 2.6 surround for 16
cakes each cake requires one 1/4 cup of
water you're just asking for Matt yeah
we've got cake monster that's why for
egg whites for 16 cakes 64 64 did I do
my math correct what guys four times I
don't like cake math are you doing all
this math anyways because I need to go
and get the groceries I've got a
question
are you put all of these in one big hole
I don't think I have a bowl big enough
this is your in a bathtub Britt use the
bucket you know cuz I want to eat this
cake this is edibles baby this is gonna
be so much fun this is gonna be
incredible so uh we gotta go get the
groceries now huh let's go
I can't believe I've got somebody in the
passenger seat it's me Jonah II don't go
straight really yeah I don't know how to
do things
and that's gonna be right here right
here this looks too good to be true
it's like i valeted today we're heading
into the grocery store to get some goods
I'm making something massive Jenna's
making something delicious and normal
and it's going to be cool you should
make this for our Oscar party all right
let's roll what's going we need some
more cake mixes so already how I think
11 12 yes I could take one lesson you
should probably get some icing just in
case but all you need a lot of it yeah
so I can use this to make icing in case
you run out oh we need this
I'm just going to get a bunch because I
always need it to cook me a lot of eggs
9 daddy healthiest hotdogs succeed for
the dog
I just want these I just don't know
that sounds great let's get it look you
need something else
fast-forward later on in the day I lost
five days worth of log but it because of
a stupid piece of crap SD card reader
I'm still upset because it's footage
that I can never ever get back we got
footage of Maddy in the studio video of
him and its trainings so many great
videos that I was going to be using this
documentary and now it's gone I got the
I have the footage from the GoPro so
that's on there that's here now
you could probably maybe just like draw
what happened but I'm not a good draw
everyone else can draw
I'm Nathan oh dude yeah I'm so excited
to show you guys something I can show
you some other footage that I would have
showed you is last night when we went to
get sushi and Maddie was there and he
had a great time he was like who's a
very good boy although anytime somebody
would come in or whatever they pay me
back chopping up this Maddie be like he
would do you do a little bark like whoop
that's over there
human Matt hi Matt had a great time last
night going out it was a good time mmm I
I indulge I have fun some adult
beverages I'm having a mint iced tea and
it is great Cheers Betty you can't go
there this is a I go there let's put you
over here but I wanted to blanket this
is not working out I'll just give you
the blanket and I'll go do my work over
here how's it go again last night was
absolutely insane the video that we made
it's not going to be out for a few weeks
because it's kind of themed around a
certain event it actually might be even
longer but I'm pretty excited about it
so take me a really long time to edit
but we rigged up the GoPro to be in the
kitchen ceiling light so that's going to
add a whole nother perspective for
cooking videos and I'm pretty excited
that
it's it looks good today is I'm not sure
what day my vlogs have been totally
messed up because of losing footage and
it's very upsetting but either way I
hope you guys enjoyed this random video
I'm not sure what you saw never really
sure but we're gonna play some Far Cry
yes we are we're gonna watch the Oscars
and I'm gonna shoot a couple more videos
and then this week is gonna be pretty
wild because my sister's bachelorette
party and she has 16 rows going well
counting us and Francesca
no it's it's there's a lot of them let's
just say it's gonna get crazy so I'm
pretty excited about that I think I'm
excited I might not be excited I'm
scared I'm terrified for what may happen
so staying at the Venetian and every
time that we stay there we always see
this little boat thing and I gondola as
in a boat
gelila as in a freight car so gondola is
something yeah but it's a free car 7
months and 5 dislikes she's like oh
we're to be riding the gondola I was
like I said gondola wait I'm using roses
there are lots of who are
intentionally pronouncing incorrect Oh
long story short I was mispronouncing
gondola I said gondola but gondola
apparently is a freight train and gone
the Lagann it doesn't even matter we're
gonna ride the boat we're gonna have a
great time and that's it Gabbar is my
snapchat reaction to Leonardo DiCaprio
winning an Oscar on me I'm ready to
tweet and everything you know